I'm not going
to bullshit you.
I know you. You've seen the
news.
The current administration
is separating families
from their children
at our border with Mexico.
Nearly 2000 children
separated from their families.
If you come across the border
we're going to take
your children away.
OK. Come across the border.
We take your children away.
That sounds harsh
but that's also the policy
of witches and candy houses.
The upside down and Fuddruckers.
Side note, do not take
your children to Fuddruckers.
Now of course with this story
the anti-Trump media
is turning the outrage up to 11
claiming these poor kids
are in cages.
But if there's anything
disturbing about the situation
it's the word choice.
Border Patrol people
have reached out to us.
They were very uncomfortable
in their words
with his characterization
of the words cages.
They said it's not inaccurate
but they're very uncomfortable
with using the word cages.
Yes very uncomfortable.
The word cages
is so uncomfortable
it's almost confining in a way.
Can you imagine
being forced into
using the word cages
to accurately describe
where you're putting children.
I mean the left
is all up in arms
over Trump's new
zero tolerance policy
that is separating immigrant
kids from their families.
If you think about it for a
second literally only a second.
It sounds really really bad.
Like movie villain bad
like where the guys who phone up
and say "we have your daughter
"I hope you don't have
a special set of skills
"or else you'll find...
...us."
But guys,
don't let them shame you.
That's OK.
Don't be afraid of these
actions. You need to understand.
This is who we are.
We're the side that supports
separating kids
from their parents.
We're the deplorables.
Now if you voted for
the Trump administration
or are in the
Trump administration
you might be feeling
a little itch
and that fist sized spot
between your lungs.
And that's just growing
pains, sorry, shrinking pains.
You're working through
the different stages
of self acceptance.
For example denial.
Homeland Security
secretary, Kirsten Nielsen
defending the administration's
immigrant policies
in a series of tweets
writing this.
We do not have a policy
of separating families
at the border.
Period.
Oh good luck following up
with that she said "Period."
National conversation over
and if someone says "what about
all those children over there?"
Just say "well let's move
onto the next stage."
-Blame. -I hate the children
being taken away.
The Democrats have to change
their law. That's their law.
That's the Democrats law.
Democrats forced that law
upon our nation.
Yes Trump can't just undo
something the Democrats did.
It's not health care,
or taxes, or gun laws,
or anything Obama touched.
His hands are tied. No sure.
Trump's own Department
of Justice
has acknowledged
that Trump and Sessions
created the policy and he can
halt it anytime he pleases.
But if Trump really had that
power then who was he tweeting
"Change the laws" to in
all caps at 8:50 am?
You heard him Twitter.
I don't know which one of you
eggs is in charge of this but
(bleep) fix it!
Unbelievable, wake up eggs!
If you're still uncomfortable
with what's happening
at the border.
Try moving on to the next
stage: appeal to a higher power.
The attorney general
Jeff Sessions turn to the Bible
to say the government
must follow the law
I will cite you to
the Apostle Paul in his clear
and wise command in Romans 13
to obey the laws of
the government
because God is
ordained.
The government for his purposes.
Jeff Sessions is always
appealing to a higher power.
He needs to appeal
to higher powers
whether it's asking for help
getting the peanut butter
off the top shelf
or getting him a booster seat
so he can draft up
some mandatory minimums
for skateboarding.
He needs it.
Now these are all
extremely valid responses
to a traumatic news cycle.
But remember the goal
is acceptance.
Luckily one man
is already there.
Steven Miller has been
the architect
of basically anything
related to immigration.
Here's what Steven Miller
told The New York Times
that the separation of children
from their families
was a "simple decision
by the administration
to have a zero tolerance
policy for illegal entry.
Period."
Period.
The Trump administration
knows how important
it is to say "period"
at the end of a sentence.
Because, like a child, that
dot is so small
it might completely lose
track of itself otherwise.
That's right.
The guy who was accepted
and helped dictate America's
southern border policy
is the same person who
reportedly told a classmate
they couldn't be friends anymore
because the classmate
was Latino.
Oh.
Yeah. Helen's face may have
launched a thousand ships
but if those ships had seen this
face it would have turned the
(bleep) around.
So, Trump administration
members. Stop being
so defensive
don't pretend this isn't
your vision. Accept it.
Because this is who we are.